swashbuckling action weird fish people
and more foot action than my ex's only
fans Netflix's live adaptation of one
piece is finally here and thank God it's
better than Cowboy Bebop you'll never
know
until you've tasted the testicles
what in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into season one of one piece
it's ending and what it could mean for
season two I've saved all the manga
anime spoilers till the end of the video
but I'll warn you when that section
comes up for those who want to remain
spoiler free but let's be honest to
watch the entire anime which started in
1999 it would take a whopping 420 hours
or 17 and a half full days of non-stop
watching ain't nobody got time for that
I do so sit back and eat a delicious
devil fruit at baratier because it's gum
gum time
welcome to the great pirate era and era
starting after the death of the most
famous of all Pirates gold Roger over
his Decades of swashbuckling the man has
amassed a level of wealth Fame and power
never before seen hiding all this
treasure together in one piece hence the
name of the show but the only clue as to
the Treasure's whereabouts come from
gold Roger himself Free Yourself
take to the Seas my treasure is yours to
find but that was 22 years ago and still
no one has found this treasure the
events of the first season lead us to
the Konomi Islands located in the East
blue this is where Nami whose name means
wave in Japanese was raised in nearby
Cocoa Village a village which is under
the brutal authoritarian rule of the
fish man arlong and his pirate gang Nami
is an orphan having been found by a
marine by the name of belmare a French
word meaning beautiful mother along with
another orphan girl named nojiko Bell
mayor had been fighting pirates in
oycott Kingdom an Island located to the
south of Konomi it also happens to be
Tokyo spelled backwards it's there she
found these two and decided to raise
them on her own but with belmare's death
at the hands of arlong Nami makes a
secret deal to ensure the safety of her
people Nami will work for arlong in
exchange for the ability to buy back
Coco Village for the princely sum of 100
million Berry the currency in the world
of one piece this is where we begin the
events of the final episode Nami finds
out that arlong never intended to make
good on their deal and even betrays Nami
by burning down her Village and
disclosing to Captain Izumi the
whereabouts of her hidden stash of money
she's lost everything but luckily her
friends of the straw hat Pirates led by
Monkey D Luffy have her back even though
she betrayed them by giving up their map
of the grand line to arlong the Grand
line is a dangerous stretch of islands
that stretch across the world with many
of them possessing unpredictable
phenomenon the only group to ever
successfully sail across its entire
length were the Roger Pirates led by
gold Roger and it is said his one-piece
treasure lay somewhere in its midst now
you might ask yourself why would Luffy
and his crew risk their lives going
after someone who betrayed them that's
because deep down Luffy knows Nami is a
good person and because she is a friend
and crewmate he must do everything he
can to get her back now mommy had no
friends growing up and refuses to make
new ones stating told you in the bar I
didn't have any friends
as I always end up hurting the people
closest to me it's only when she's lost
everything that she turns to Luffy and
asks for his help
[Music]
Luffy always knew deep down that nami's
heart was good
no he's good
he's to know it too even though she did
a bad thing it was for a good reason and
this theme of good versus evil is a
common one throughout one piece with
Luffy being instilled with the
importance of goodness even though he's
a pirate by his hero Shanks not
everything can be solved with violence a
man needs to be strong
it also needs to be good into Hammer
home this theme Shanks his last words to
Luffy are be good
with the crew together they can finally
take down arlong save Coco Village and
continue on their quest for the one
piece normally taking on the stronghold
of a pirate warlord would be suicide but
Luffy's a mastis skilled crew each with
their own unique abilities and one of
the things I really liked about the show
are how the characters have different
motivations or dreams as they called in
the show to travel alongside Luffy first
there's roronoa Zorro a famous pirate
Hunter whose dream is to become the
world's best swordsman they show
brilliantly includes flashbacks which
contextualize their dreams as a teenager
Zorro made a promise with his friend
shimotsuki quina that one of them would
become the world's greatest swordsman
but after her tragic death he alone must
fulfill that promise bringing honor not
only to himself but to her Legacy these
dreams also come with their own
obstacles and in zoro's case it's the
world's greatest swordsman the pirate
warlord mihawk in episode 5 Zorro is
spared from Death after challenging
mihawk to a duel he's nowhere near the
strength to become the world's greatest
at least not yet mihawk senses this and
Spares him stating it's too soon for you
to die
grow strong and come find me dreams are
also the only thing that will prevent
Luffy from saving his friends he
explains he didn't help Zorro in his
battle against mihawk because I'd do
anything to save him
except stand in the way of his dream a
dream is so important it's at the core
of what makes someone a pirate you gave
up on your dream
no one who does that can ever call
themselves a pirate master of
hand-to-hand combat expert chef and
somehow has amazing ABS Sanji has a
dream of finding the all-blue a sea of
Legend where it said the north south
east and west seas meet it's here it's
rumored the most delicious plants Meats
herbs and spices can be found allowing
Sanji to take his culinary skills to the
next level usop the slingshot wielding
Captain wannabe has dreams of becoming a
brave Warrior of the sea Nami wants to
map the entire world and of course
there's Luffy who wants to find the one
piece and become king of the Pirates all
these dreams revolve around exploring
the great unknown and while their
individual dreams may be different
they're all bound together on this
journey through friendship but arlong is
in their way he has Master plans of
using his maps to conquer the world and
enslave Humanity a sort of Revenge for
how Humanity enslaved fishmen decades
ago it's pretty ironic that arlong
fought against slavery yet enslaves Nami
for years and this culminates in an epic
battle between Luffy and arlong normally
Luffy would be made mince meat up
against a guy three times his size and
it's even said that fishermen have 10
times the strength of a normal human but
Luffy has a magic power he can stretch
and contort his body which allows him to
do all sorts of cool moves this was made
possible when as a child he ate a devil
fruit aptly named because it said you
make a deal with the devil when you eat
one other characters have eaten said
fruit such as buggy the clown but no two
fruits Grant the same ability buggy ate
what he calls a chop chop fruit which
allows him to cut his body into several
parts and control them individually now
there is a downside to eating devil
fruit in both buggy and arlong exploit
this weakness against Luffy those who
eat devil fruit lose the ability to swim
in the sea a pretty bad weakness if you
plan on spending all your time exploring
it buggy puts Luffy in a tank of
seawater and in episode 5 arlong throws
Luffy in the sea where he'd drown unless
he were saved but luckily this final
battle between the Luffy and arlong is
more evenly matched and Luffy uses the
environment to his Advantage knocking
out the pillars of arlong's map room and
collapsing the building on him along
with his aspirations of taking over the
world with the village saved and the
Fishman defeated it seems all is good if
it weren't for the arrival of vice
admiral GARP of the Marines halfway
through the season we learned that GARP
is Luffy's grandfather an overbearing
man who dreamed that Luffy would follow
in his footsteps and become a Marine but
Luffy's always wanted to be a pirate
this is the first time we really see
GARP fight and I gotta say he's much
stronger than Luffy but GARP even after
crushing Luffy understands that
absolutely nothing will get in the way
of his grandson's dream Luffy's laughter
even reminds him of gold Rogers the man
he executed over 22 years ago according
to garpinu all along he wasn't going to
be able to change Luffy's mind thus this
was all a test to see if Luffy knew
himself this was the life for him a test
that Luffy passes so the vice admiral
lets Luffy and the straw hats go even
though we'll see Luffy get the highest
Bounty ever seen in the East blue a
wanted poster is shown to him by Kobe
another character who has been on their
own Journey this season his dream was to
become a Marine but that dream seemed
Dash when he learns how the world
actually works Kobe saw the world very
black and white the good Marines fought
against the evil Pirates and by joining
the Marines he'd be protecting those he
loved but when he finds out about this
secret alliance between the world
government which controls the Marines
and the Seven warlord Pirates Who
control the Pirates he can't believe the
organization he idolized would be
working with the very people he sought
to destroy as GARP tells him the world
isn't black and white but rather a hazy
gray the deal with the Pirates was a
necessary evil to keep the Warlords
close and and prevent all-out Anarchy
the world is no fail
are all that are standing between order
and Anarchy a reluctant Kobe decides to
remain with the Marines and is even
taken under the wing of GARP to be
personally trained by him at her
mother's grave Nami says goodbye stating
for the first time in her life she's
finally free she even leaves a tangerine
windmill something she played with as a
child you may even have noticed her
arlong tattoo has been changed Luffy's
wanted poster makes its way all across
the East blue and now not only will
Luffy and his crew have to fend off
Marines but bounty hunters looking for a
Payday this includes buggy who is able
to get his body back after being set
free by Zorro and Sanji and it looks
like he'll be teaming up with alvida the
captain of The alvita Pirates Who had
their ships set on fire by Luffy and
Kobe at the beginning of the season so
she definitely has her reasons for
getting back at Luffy there's also a
nice Montage of other characters we've
seen throughout this season Finding
Luffy's wanted poster from Makino the
bartender Luffy's Hometown at Windmill
Village Kaya usop's friend and Ally of
the strong hats and zeff my name is Jeff
owner of the famous baratier restaurant
but it's the greatest swordsman mihawk
who informs Shanks that Luffy has begun
his journey to become king of the
Pirates something that is a cause for
celebration the season ends with a nice
little gift of Tangerine trees to make
Nami feel more at home as the team
reiterates their dreams before heading
towards the grand line it's a fantastic
way to re-establish what's at stake for
everyone there and remind us why they're
on this journey but there's still a lot
to talk about which leads me into the
spoiler section keep in mind the show
could deviate from the manga so what
might happen in season 2 could change we
know that the first season of One Piece
covered roughly the first 100 chapters
of the manga so we can assume that next
season will cover the next 100 this
means we'll see the crew save the nation
of arabasta from crocodile and the
addition of chopper as the ship's doctor
crocodile was the former president of
the mysterious crime syndicate known as
Baroque works you may remember that a
bounty hunter known as Mr Seven was
working for Baroque works and tried to
recruit Zorro in episode 1. we even see
their business card throughout the
season Nami also refers to a river on
the map which seems to go up a mountain
defying physics this is a reference to
reverse Mountain an entrance to the
Grand line where Four Rivers one from
each of the blue Seas converge Atop A
Mountain leading to a separate river
that leads to the Grand line buggy and
alvida joined forces creating the buggy
and alvita Alliance I wonder if we'll
see elvita eat that devil fruit like she
does in the manga which allows her to
shed her excess weight completely
changing her look finally we have the
reveal of marine Captain smoker
evidenced by the iconic two cigars he
holds in his hands and the trademark
naval uniform lined with green fur the
first time Luffy and his crew meet him
he's the Marine captain in charge of
logtown which you may remember is the
same place where gold Rogers was
executed he ate a devil fruit which
allows him the ability to transform his
body into smoke if we're going by the
manga he is the next villain in the
series but appears as a recurring and
tag in several story arcs down the line
but now I want to turn it over to you
what did you think of the live-action
one piece and what do you think they
should cover in season two I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember
foreign